hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen today we are gonna be making
eggs and eggs is pretty much the only
thing that I actually am really good at
but I'm throwing myself for quite the
curveball today because we are gonna be
making egg shapes egg ARCT I don't know
but I'm pretty excited about it I've got
a couple different molds here this one
is a little dog we've got a little bunny
I'm not sure if this is it potentially
could be a cat owl frog
okay so let's spray this up let's do the
frog put the egg whites in first there
that's what Oh freaking fantastic and
yolk broke oh give it a little
jiggle okay so it's not a toy it's food
safe dishwasher safe this is supposed to
be easy and so no I definitely mess this
up I guess this will just be a warm-up
well this is looking like trash I guess
I'll just call this one fail and try
again
so I guess maybe if I just like cut
around the edges of this is this is a
practice this is supposed to be so easy
Oh what is he Oh what I think his eyes
about the pop this is not at all what I
was expecting
well I guess I'll flip him over oh my
gee this looks like roadkill this is
actually shocking how terrible this
turned out I'm pretty upset about it
we're gonna get this we're gonna get
this is gonna be fantastic
bring you up I'm upset I haven't even
started yet haven't even started and I
know it's not gonna work out okay I'm
gonna save that I for later get a little
more yep oh gosh okay oh shoot yes like
that that's not right
I'm gonna put a lid over top of it so
that it'll also be cooking at the top
too so I've got a little hole right here
so I'm gonna drop some water in there I
just wanted to make something successful
and nice for my audience for once that
is such a small Oh No oh god what have I
done a water and oil mmm what do you
never throw on a grease fire water it's
steaming though should I just delete
this video should turn it up just a
little bit more steam Oh Oh get in there
Oh set our food post mates okay I'm
pretty surprised with how this is
looking
I've got a concern though because the
yolks are overpowering and like over top
of the face but I don't even know if
it'll do anything with this look look oh
god oh god burning my body look at him
okay your different-colored yet okay
well how am I going to get him out of
here is the question
freaking off of their garbage out okay
okay okay I think it looks good this is
like pancake art full with eggs oh boy
oh boy alright so there's one you know
when people question and say just see
you have zero talons gonna be like look
what I made
so this one is a little bit more premium
it was way more expensive than the other
ones flop in our eggs into the eyes
[Music]
there we go one two and now we cover and
now we wait
play post Malone better now I think this
might actually work out pretty well
okay well jeez oh God
out get in there oh I'm trying to get
the water to go that way oh no now it's
cooking too much I'll shoot now I just
like freaking boiled a well here it is
this looks excellent I'm extremely
excited about it I think this is where I
will make my exit that I might need to
do a little more practicing I don't
think I'm prepared to make this for
friends or family or you guys yet if you
have any suggestions on what I was doing
wrong feel free to leave them in the
comments below but I'm pretty sure that
I already know what I did wrong but this
looks surprisingly a little better than
the previous one if you guys want to
recall this is where we started so
here's one a tweet Drake so that he
knows that I am dressed like him
I started from the bottom now I'm here
it's okay I'm gonna flip this just cuz I
can
oh wow wow so alright well I thank you
so much for watching hope you guys
somewhat enjoy this and if you didn't
I'm completely and totally okay with
that that's all I've got now and I will
hopefully see you guys in the next video
if you guys have any fun suggestions for
things that you would like to see me
make here if you have any fun kitchen
tech be sure to leave those also in the
comments below and be sure to subscribe
so you can see me potentially not
messing up something in the next video
unless you like seeing me mess up then
you're mean see you later
[Music]